[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm linked joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is the creator of
one of the most popular songs the
internet has ever heard Chocolate Rain
that's right
Tay Zonday now if you had a computer in
2007 or at least a library card that
allowed you to go to the internet
section of your local library
you remember Chocolate Rain this video
went viral back in that summer and
immediately propelled Tay to the
Internet Hall of Fame he quickly became
the subject of parodies tributes remixes
everybody wanted a piece of that sweet
Chocolate Rain and today nearly eight
years later Chocolate Rain has racked up
over 100 million views and for those of
you who didn't have a computer or a
library card in 2007 I'm gonna give you
a refresher I know you've seen Chocolate
Rain since then but I just want to
describe it because it's even fun to
just describe it to have it wash over
you even without even seeing it and
Chocolate Rain the say Pia coloured
video portrays Tay wearing a white
t-shirt and singing in a microphone with
his signature deep voice there's
occasional cuts to tape playing the
keyboard and every once in a while he
according to the text that he placed on
the screen quote moves away from the mic
to breathe in Chocolate Rain is a staple
in the internet pantry people not pantry
people I was I was referring in the
pantry people he's created a kind of
online nostalgia really that immediately
transports you back to the moment you
first heard Chocolate Rain it's like
when I don't know when like JFK died for
like our parents or something or when
you had your first child or that mm-hmm
kind of like that it's kind of like
having a baby listening to this song I'm
gonna transport you there again right
now
just latrine some stay dry and others
feel the pain Chocolate Rain
a baby born will die before the sim
topless ring the school say it can't be
here again Chocolate Rain the prisons
make you wonder where it went topless
ring
and say the will be dry chocolate rain
zoom and see the light chocolate rain
now the crazy over chocolate rain
eventually faded but taya's continued to
maintain a career in web video for the
past eight years and learning to ride
that wave of chocolate rain that wave of
chocolate rain get that I'm gonna use as
many of those analogies as the fact that
it's just rain its water it washes over
you can ride the wave just help me out
is dominus rink I'm gonna sprinkle you
with it it you can drink it in the ocean
so I could down is a wave it's not I
could arrange or just ring brain waves
you can if they get enough of it anyway
comes in sheets the shutting waves he
learned to ride the sheet of chocolate
rain that led him on a really
interesting journey into what it's like
to be known so well for something that
became unintentionally huge and we
talked to him about what it's like to
build a career on a moment like that
yeah we also taught to tell you about
his life before the sheets of chocolate
rain how he suffered from severe anxiety
agoraphobia and went many years
essentially being a mute we talked about
the creation of Chocolate Rain and how
he handled all the craze and instant
fame including our interview with him
back in 2007 we also talked about how he
perceives people's perception of him
perception inception he gets
psychological and I think I we both said
the word fascinating fascinating about
we're like multiple times during our
conversation would say because you know
what it was fast and it is I wasn't
doing a Spock impression you're going to
enjoy this biscuit but first we want to
tell you guys about our sponsor who
remember helps make ear biscuits a
reality for you to enjoy
EF college break the travel experts at
the FK create amazing travel experiences
for people aged 18 to 28 listen the only
boring and tedious part of travel is the
planning reserving flights and hotels
figuring out what to do when to do it
how to get from place to place all the
necessary stuff for having a truly great
trip EF College Break does all that for
you when you let you have college break
plane trip you are free to just take the
trip just enjoy the trip
and what are you gonna be enjoying well
they've created a bunch of unique travel
experiences you can browse right on
their website trips like touring London
and Paris heavy cruising the islands of
Thailand embarking on a coastal
adventure in Australia oh that was bad
Australia what about traveling through
the green landscapes of Ireland what
about it sounds good I would do it if I
could but I'm too old and I got I got I
got too many stuffs I've got to take
care of and we got stuffs even if you
sign it by yourself you'll be grouped
together with other travelers so do it
if you head over to our special URL EF
college break comm slash rhett and Link
we'll hook you up with an extra $100 off
your next adventure that's right for
$100 off go to EF college break comm
slash rhett and Link and now onto the
biscuit I've been looking forward to
having this conversation I know you kind
of came in here last minute we
appreciate that but I will say that I've
been looking forward to having the Tay
Zonday your biscuit for quite a while
there's a number of questions and we've
got we've got quite a history to go
through not only with you as a person
and as a performer but also with us
collectively I think there's some good
stuff yes we want to hit on definite but
you know having not released videos this
year yet on either of your YouTube
channels we were trying to you know do
some research do some catch-up and one
of the first things we found was an
article out there that's multiple
multiple articles Wow alright seeing
that you were spotted shopping for
engagement rings with your girlfriend
are you engaged I'm behind the times on
this I need to apparently I need to be
reading TMZ well that was the only one
of the articles find the latest on
tayzonday well the second article said
that you had had a secret wedding
ceremony oh my goodness
I am just behind the time now I hasten
down behind the fanfiction
so there's scene at your face I'm trying
to figure out are you legitimately
surprised and you you do legitimately
look taking a back ride
oh no I'm not glad you engaged I
actually am NOT I am not engaged you
know I don't have time for relationships
even people are always asked hello
you're not even in a relationship my
goodness I seriously I can't even find
time to like tie my shoes I seriously
and it's funny because people always
okay you must get all the ladies you
must get all the whatever like you who
are you after like yeah I mean well but
be surprised how dull my life there's no
in its the interesting thing is is
they're seeing these articles there's
this one source this one source it's
difficult to ascertain the reliability
of this source given our conversation
already but also given the nature of
this website when we were just trying to
catch up on haha one of the things that
it multiple articles including and
engage the engagement the secret looking
for engagement rings very large diamond
heist oration of day on day I want a
secret ceremony with a quote from a
close friend I'm not kidding it was just
like this is I you don't know about this
apparently I haven't been googling
myself lately okay well I'm gonna look
so you haven't you you're not engaged
you don't have a girlfriend have you
been like just perusing the diamond
section just for I I actually have not
but see every time you say that I think
you're about to say I actually have
you're like I actually am engaged but
you're like I actually am NOT you keep
hooking me well no I mean honestly it's
the most boring topic I could possibly
think of like I think the media and the
world kind of fascinates about these
aspects of your personal life when you
two go through this I mean this is you
know you're you're kind of big-time now
you can't either semi-famous you have
the speculation and the fanfic I'm sure
you've seen yourself and you know
different cartoon configurations and
whatever else people do yes I do out
they've heard about it about you we have
him we have team members who tell us do
not marry the fan members I mean link
fanfic no I I am thoroughly enjoying
this tay zonday for much more no but I
have got to read the headlines of some
of these art because this is this is
this one source that is
now that now that I'm reading the titles
of the articles I'm realizing this is a
like a whole celebrity news spoof site
and what give us the day this is like
very recent this is not like a year ago
this is like a - few days ago today that
were requires it April third of the day
we're recording this hiepro second so
it's the day after April Fool's all
right so if we did this April Fool but
it's not Tay Zonday nude photos leaked
online oh my goodness
Tay Zonday x' dog recovering from
surgery Tay Zonday secretly married that
was today Tay Zonday named sexiest
singer alive that was yesterday okay Tay
Zonday TIME's Person of the Year 2015
this is all one website what's the name
of the website media mass net Tay Zonday
to be a dad
Tay Zonday goes Gangnam style Tay Zonday
Tay Zonday is the highest-paid singer in
the world that was yesterday and Tay
Zonday new album in 2015 world tour this
you don't know in charge of his website
are you I apparently not though I mean
it some of them I'll take you know hey
is this your version of listen you know
what they say about all publicity it's
suspicious is so intriguing this point
just why I say about rhettandlink got
nothing it said oh it says nothing about
come on hit meaning the Internet I mean
this website it's a satire site guys oh
yeah which that makes a whole lot of
sense now but they're fixated on
satirizing you oh it's a no you're mean
media mass is a parody news site best
known for debunking celebrity rumors
this is like us just lot live on the air
discovering the I am I feel like this is
a paid promotion for media seems like it
I are they handing money under the table
let's see what it says about it let's
see what it says about us guys and I'm
gonna be disappointed if it doesn't say
anything about us but there's a Tay
Zonday article for every single day is
it automatically generating it says
absolutely nothing about us you have
like 50 articles oh man well you know I
guess we playboy I am winning that
procedurally generated algorithmic
satire article game can you expound upon
this recent tweet in your Twitter feed
now this is posted on April Fool's Day
it
I'm tired of lying I'm attracted to
aliens I want to cuddle an alien feel
tentacles all over my body and make
interspecies children now you see I
think that April Fool's is like Vegas in
terms of what happens on April Fool's
stays in April Fool's and so it is April
2nd I think saying that it's April 2nd
is kind of like pleading the fifth so I
am just going to separate myself from
all actions all digital trails that were
left by me on April 1st but but can I
make an observation you can make it up
ok so you've just confirmed that this
was an April Fool's Day prank tweet from
you but I think it that's that gives
insight into your sis of humor because
it's not it's such a bizarre tweet you
thought he was serious no I'm just
saying if this is a joke it's an
interest I mean I believe these articles
about him getting married yeah you're
the one who fell for that I'm just
saying that tell you if I read this if I
read this sincerely well that's it's
weird if I read it as an April Fool's
prank tweet it's still weird interesting
now why is that cuz it's not it I guess
this is the review the reverse interview
yeah you said you're like was hilarious
okay okay I thought it was riveting you
are you put you were playing into like
the way that people like to speculate
about you like I bet he wants to make
love to an alien no no but but I think
you kind of hit because the larger
question here a larger problem is like I
have problems with whenever I try to be
deliberately funny ah I cannot be
deliberately funny I can only be
incidentally funny okay and this is that
defines my career where it's like I can
be just being me just being every day
and not trying to be funny being
quote-unquote this straight man is it's
called an improv comedy you know just
fascinating and it's fine it's many
people laugh at it like oh gosh so when
you go for the joke when I
for the joke people have the exact
reaction that you're having what's like
hey uh okay maybe that was a little bit
funny but you know it's it's also kind
of creepy like you hit the wrong no fair
dude I mean I I know you were trying to
be funny but Kazon they joke that yes
that was tazed on Days attempt at a joke
God and you're having a very typical
reaction come on I read attempts at
humor so many interesting things
happening already
but isn't it it is you know your self
analysis there I think I'd like to
unpack over the good ones get into that
get into that conversation before going
all the way back to your birth because I
do want to go all the way all the way
back let's go back to let's go back to
the first time that the three of us met
and I don't match do it now in that
hotel yes that poolside room the
Roosevelt the Roosevelt Hotel
to do a segment was it was the show
online nation yes yes yeah yes W exactly
let me and I'll set the stage here
because we we I'm glad you remember
that's amazing yeah I think we may have
touched base about this at one time over
there because this has been eight years
ago this happened just holy moly some
perspective here but we were hosting the
show online nation on the CW which some
of the listeners may know was a really
horrible show that we hosted four
episodes it was a clip show we toss to
internet video and your your video had
gone viral and either the spring or
summer or 2007 and then our show is
coming out in the fall of 2007 and there
was this whole debate about is it too
late does it make us seem out of touch
to talk about Chocolate Rain the first
episode of the end of one of the first
episodes of the season and we were like
I feel like we've got to talk about this
because it was such a big thing and they
were like well you guys you know what
you can do you can go and interview the
guy behind this thing because he's gonna
be in LA for Jimmy Kimmel right so this
is that the at the height of chocolate
roll absolutely but online nature
wouldn't the first episode would not air
for like another month until like
October that was the that was the
question of
the timing but you know we wanted to not
just be hosts but we wanted to go out on
location we wanted to we wanted to
create content and part of that if that
was an interview then hey we were fine
with that you know it was our first it
was our first time working in LA we had
visited and you know we were intimidated
by everything and then now we're we're
being told okay we've got like 20
minutes
with you know what what we all called
the Chocolate Rain guy you know we
didn't know you Estee even though we
knew that was your name we were gonna
interview you and yeah I guess Kimmel
had put you up at the at the Roosevelt
side room Roosevelt and it's funny you
recounting that experience of LA because
that was actually my first experience as
an adult at least since I was you know a
kid I've been there a couple times but
uh and I just remember that sense of awe
being amazed like you know you feel the
sunlight on Hollywood and Highland and
it kind of exists weird filtered by
pollution sunlight yeah that you don't
get in in the south in the Midwest and
it's like Minnesota where you were
Minnesota where I was at the time and so
it just that sense of LA being so new
right and feeling different and I was
totally green at the time of that
interview like that was just like me
being caught up in the whirlwind of the
craziness of not knowing what to do and
we we can illustrate that because we go
- yeah we go to your door we knock on
your door with our producer and your
manager who is also you're a relative of
yours or somebody at the time I think
you were traveling with like a was a
brother or a cousin or my brother was
there but somebody who was handling you
at the time
all right comes to the door and says
well what we opened the door and we can
see through the door which is on the
hallway side I can we can look through
your room and see the pool where we
wanted to set up the interview yes and
so hi we're here I remember being a
weird awkward situation somehow is this
what we're getting - yeah yeah we were
like remember exactly what it was but it
was it felt very awkward you're gone
your guard was up and we were like can
we you know we wouldn't you mind if we
do the interview pull
side and you were like sure and then we
were like okay can we just can we just
walk through your room get to the pool
it's right there and you were like no I
prefer that you walk around in boundary
mode we could have been anybody at that
point well you were anybody I wasn't
expecting a film crew like I think I was
just kind of freaked out I mean cause we
had a guy with a camera he's gonna walk
through your room yeah and I I have so
many stories of just kind of being a
little bit freaked out by the
entertainment industry and now it's just
like if a film crew mr. Cruz came and I
was like hey you know sure come and do
whatever I know what they do I think at
that time I was just literally I went
from being a nerd and we'll get to this
if we're starting for my birth but I
guess the voices go in there yeah I was
literally a nerd in my living room
making music as a hobby singing in front
of bed sheets and Chocolate Rain sat
around for two or three months without
going viral right it was posted on the
front page of Digg which is kind of like
reddit back in that day the view is
doubled in a week someone saw it on Digg
posted on a 4chan kind of became a joke
there and they prank called it's on
green show and it just kind of started
to take off bro but but the point
getting back to that moment the hotel
yeah is that I was so swept up by like
literally in a period of a couple weeks
30 or 40 radio interviews were completed
by me in a very very it was a whirlwind
whirlwind you know you know agents of
all types booking agents and publishing
agents and everyone and their mother
people wanting me to sing at their Bar
Mitzvah sing at their corporate parties
sing every was trying to contact me
about this video and I was literally
still just a nerd in my living room
inside and this is the thing that I want
to get into as we talk about like you
know that video kind of catapulting you
to fame is that sense that at that time
was probably the beginning of you
figuring out exactly what people were
seeing and then cutting and being like
okay I'm
beginning to interpret understand what
they're interpreting me as and how I'm
playing into that absolutely so I think
the best way to come back to that and
talk about you know Chocolate Rain and
in the last eight years is to go back to
the beginning all right and who you are
where you're from Oh Michael so you
start out you're not you're not teh the
moniker yet you are Adam I am born Adam
bought er some time in 1982 while living
in Chicago okay I am the youngest of
three by quite a bit
my brother's six years older my sisters
11 years older I would say being around
older people all of the time
tremendously shaped my personality I
always felt very driven to be an act
older than I was at every age and I
think it also contributed to my being
very much an observer I observed the
behavior and other people and you know I
observe and I mimic and I think that
tends to be a dominant aspect of my
personality even today okay what was
what was the parental situation both
parents in the house both parents in the
house very very lucky to have two
parents and they are still wonderfully
married to this day and a lot of kids
don't get that yeah mom and what it what
did they do or do now they were teachers
my dad taught high school and my mom
taught elementary school and then she
was a principal for twenty years and you
know I think the the benefit of that as
a parent is you get to see how other
people's kids turn out and you kind of I
don't know if that shapes I mean I don't
know first of all is it because we've
kind of started with the relationship
silliness you know right first of all
being in a relationship is a sustaining
relationship is one of the hardest
things you can do and so I I am
absolutely amazed that my parents or
anyone else has been married a long
period of time I mean that is hard to be
with one person for 20 30 40 years but
then to have kids and raise kids and
again that is one of the most difficult
things you can
ever do and I had no appreciation of
this as a kid so I think these are
insights that I I kind of get being an
adult being 32 almost 33 now reflecting
back on my childhood I think I see it
with much rosier glasses and much more
forgiving glasses because I'm kind of in
the world I'm like wow that must have
been really really hard yeah
does your explanation of being kind of
the young kid chameleon looking up to
the older people kind of growing up
early another way people put that is
he's got an old soul absolutely
I had a tremendously old soul and and
you know everyone told me that when I
was like 10 years old so it wasn't just
something you you reapplied in
retrospect because people asked about
well you got the deep voice and well
surely you're affecting your voice and
things of this nature
where it's people start to question and
try to deconstruct you that you derive
the reasons for that or is it something
that even back then your parents were
like yeah you were he was always an old
son I was always very much an old soul
yeah I remember one of my favorite role
models when I was 9 10 years old was
Lieutenant Commander data on stock
generation and I loved the idea and also
Spock and the original Star Trek I love
the idea of being reserved and super
intellectual and somehow greater than my
own humanity now I read somewhere
hopefully not on rets website yeah that
your parents discourage you from
listening to popular music so what what
was behind that I would say that my
parents you know because you got you you
got piano lessons and like voice lessons
early on like music was a big part of
your child's lessons but I did I did
take some piano lessons I was no
particularly good at them but I had took
a few years of piano um I would say that
you know my parents were fairly strict I
mean I you know Bing schoolteachers and
I think seeing other people's kids and
whatever I don't know what their
motivations were but you know I'd say
they definitely had a
vision of prim and proper MARY POPPINS
kids that that was kind of you know
their sense of a well-put-together
family and you know is there any
religious motivation behind that I don't
think it was religious conservatives
because we were certainly I was raised
Methodist Christian we went to to church
certainly but I think it was almost kind
of like like when I was a kid I wasn't
allowed to play with violent action
figures couldn't we couldn't have
weapons we couldn't so I think like a
man or something yeah I actually
remember he-man and Shera
from when I was like three four years
old my room I wasn't allowed to play
with action figures all that had weapons
or GI Joes or that type of thing I don't
know I mean I think it it was something
that they meant well you know they're
like okay don't have you kid don't have
a key Plan C I do so they don't become
violent or whatever I mean I I think
there are so many things you do when you
parent that it's like you just kind of
make the best call that you are able to
make at that point in your life and you
know I certainly there have been times
in my past where maybe I would be a
little bit angry about some of the more
hurtful restrictions or whatever because
you're right I mean I didn't feel free
to listen to a lot of popular music
growing up I felt and and part of that
again was what I described earlier this
very internal pressure I had to always
be older always see more proper always
seemed more reserved always seemed more
adults than even the adults around me
and so I think that also kind of fed
into this sense of well you know don't
listen to you know who's popular than
you know Nirvana Korn Rage Against the
Machine etc so you were raised in a pop
music vacuum I think that's that's fair
to say and I mean so what what would you
pull from for a Chocolate Rain then well
and in fact what's interesting is I was
raised in pop music vacuum but then the
internet came along when I was 12 or 13
years old
and around 13 14 I started being able to
download mp3s and the internet was this
wonderful place where it's like I
realized I could do any
and my parents couldn't see what I was
doing and so it kind of became this
second life so to speak which is why
sometimes I think I relate so much to
two kids in the digital generation now
cuz I mean it's it's all like crazy with
social media and like you know big kids
going to sleep with their phones and
whatever so what did you download you
say that almost suggestively innocent
bunnies and you know unicorns but music
though
what means though I remember the first
mp3 I ever downloaded was Will Smith's
men in black remember that kind of I
mean surely your parents would have been
upset with that right I don't know you
don't think you got to be violated
offended galaxy I don't actually know I
realized that you know I I have a lot of
perceptions I think especially when I
was young
uh I think I would perceive people very
literally when I was young and so you
know someone would say something to me
once including my parents like okay
you're not allowed to do this and like I
would remember that four or five six
seven years later I've always had kind
of that pictographic type of memory
where it's like if you say something and
I think I was brutal like this as a kid
you know where I be 17 18 years old
remember something that my mom just said
to me offhand when I was throwing to be
like oh wait you actually did say that
and / compliant like absolutely proper
that is the best word / compliant I was
an / compliant pleaser who very much
took what was said to me literally I
remember you know one time I was just
watching TV just watching full house
fairly innocent show when I was 12 years
old and and and my mom was just I don't
like you know the dialogue between you
know the the father and the daughter and
that it was a little bit you know not
what you thought was appropriate
probably where full house episodes like
that this seemed like friends not like a
parent or just I mean it was just some
seniors
we're like something was in it was
something where it's like I think my mom
would have said it I was being sassy and
yeah and forgot and she probably forgot
about it the next day but I remember
like years later I was like 16 17 almost
18 years old you know creeping up on
adulthood and still having internalized
exactly my mom said on that day as
though it was gospel and I think it took
me a while to watch full set house well
I guess it's probably Netflix now but I
mean have you watched it ever since then
I actually haven't I actually stopped
watching a whistlin and I and i watch
this marathon what else marathon no I
that actually took the flawless out of
me I think that constitutes torture nice
day and age oh it's great still great it
still holds up the to spoiler alert the
youngest girl is really twins and I kind
of figured that out eventually but you
know I made I I guess we're kind of
hitting on different points in my job I
would say you know the the extent to
which I was extremely cerebral and
extremely you know extremely pleaser uh
kind of resulted in a period of my life
from about 12 to 19 where I was just I
had such high anxiety huh
that I literally did not speak in my
house I retreated to the Internet I you
know kind of you know I played games on
the internet played a lot of Star CG was
kind of like MechWarrior played a lot of
you know it did things with my online
squad there but when you walked in the
front door I did not speak I literally I
were your parents worried did they was
there an intervention of any kind oh
yeah I mean I certainly saw plenty of
theorists and you know there was kind of
that you know the efforts to kind of
tentatively break the ice but I don't
think they actually understood the
rationale for well how would they
characterize it though because that's
one of things I wanted to touch on too
is since a lot of your your career has
been characterized by the way people
interpret you absolutely so how was that
happening at that point like did you
begin to pick up on how you were being
interpret
by friends how you being inserted by
your family your parents um and how how
would you characterize that how I was
being interpreted I mean I I would say
that if I go back to my 12 13 14 year
old brain I definitely felt very very
parented and very very um watched very
very sheltered sheltered and living in a
pad opticon where I felt like every
breath every you know step I took was
kind of thought of deeply and monitored
and even though you seem to now describe
it as more of a product of your own
brain more than your the way you the way
your parents I was a it was kind of an
unfortunate interaction between your
parents being protective but the way
your brain works absolutely and I can
say that because my brother and sister
did not have that but yeah I mean I it's
funny people ask a lot it's on it's an
oddly common question what was it like
when you boys got c4 what was it like
when your voice cracked you did you did
your parents freak out it and you know
the truth that story is uh yeah I was
selectively mutant agoraphobic for about
seven years my life as an adolescent and
really did not communicate like that in
that way and it wasn't really until I
moved out and with my parents support
their amazing parents graciously
supporting me as I moved out and went to
college and kind of had my own adult
life that then I kind of started to get
a perspective and you know well how did
you I mean how does that how does that
happen how do you go from struggling in
this way and even characterizing it as a
agoraphobic absolutely I'm going to
college because usually when someone is
struggling to that level they go to
maybe a community college they live at
home that is exactly what I did at first
I I woulds community college I lived at
home eventually we all kind of moved to
the Midwest out to Seattle lived in an
apartment there and I went to Community
College transferred down how did you
tell him where do you want to go did you
email them or you spoke occasionally you
know my sister was actually very help
at that point in kind of like when I
started to be like 1819 you know she was
she was kind of the intervention it kind
of cuz I mean she was moving on with her
life and whatever she's much older she's
coming you know what you know curly
there's some miscommunication that's
happened between who and and and mom and
dad maybe it's it's slimy kind of an
adult now let's evaluate this and you
know I I you know I am blessed to have
such wonderful people in my family
who've been supportive both my parents
and and my older siblings who've really
been there for me in those moments where
I kind of needed that type of you know
tap on the shoulder okay can we move on
from this and I think I eventually did
and so mechanically how did that happen
well it happened what was so interesting
is I lived in Capitol Hill in Seattle
when I was 19
this was right when 9/11 happened and
you know Capitol Hill is a very very
politically active you know very kind of
a eclectic artistic type community and
I'd say that's the period of my life
where I kind of started to I really
warmed up to I went to Community College
there I was in different independent
media movements I think that kind of
post 9/11 lead up to the Iraq war period
was when I kind of started to look at
the Internet is something we're okay
is this something we can attempt social
change or at least kind of create a
dialog and of course you know it really
wasn't successful then you didn't have
social media you didn't really have the
critical mass to do that with it um
but I remember because eventually I
ended up studying social change in the
relationship between performance and
social change when I proceeded a PhD at
the University of Minnesota and I think
it was kind of that moment living in
Capitol Hill where there were all sorts
of different types of you know politics
and marches and and things going on that
I kind of both came out of my shell that
I grew up in mm-hmm and became
acclimated to different types of people
and was that because those those
movements usually involve actually
getting to know and interact with people
is that what kind of drew you out like
oh I'm into
this movement or I want to go be a part
of this group like how do you begin to
have those interactions with people
where you start feeling like okay no I
can be social I can speak like do you
remember a moment um I don't know if I
remember a moment I mean so much of my
agoraphobia and not feeling safe outside
was a fear that my parents would like
when I was like 17 16 18 feet a fear of
my parents would drive by and see me
being normal or see me doing something
they would not approve of and I
literally clamped up and and shut down
to the for that reason not like I didn't
go outside I was afraid of like that
that I would be out in so to speak by by
being seen by that panopticon and you
know I I think at some point you know I
I was you know my parents were so good
to me when I was you know again I mean
they a lot of kids you know when they're
not 18 I did in their auto house had to
support themselves you know my parents
were very generous I mean they they they
paid for me to be in an apartment I was
there by myself they paid me to be
independent they kind of knew what I
needed in order to transition into
adulthood and they gave it to me and I
was just I was very lucky because not
every person who came from where I came
from has that level of support in that
level of of just doggedness and saying
hey this is how we're gonna do this and
this is and you know it was effective
like and I remember you know I it was
just uh I kind of discovered who I was
or started to discover who I was in that
period of time when I was nineteen
twenty years old and what was that
discovery yeah I think it's still
ongoing this is still ongoing you know
twelve thirteen years later but just
being able I mean sometimes I I remember
I was just walking around Capitol Hill
one day and Capitol Hill was in at that
period of time was a neighborhood we
could literally just be walking around
you you see a March you see like
protestors and plays it was just like
you know marching I've been in organized
march and I remember one time I was just
walking outside Seattle Central
Community College where I was going
school and they were having what they
self call this is their title you know
that they call the Dyke mark you know
celebrating you know that community
whatnot and I had no idea what being
transgendered or lesbian or anything was
or take much but I just like oh wait
it's a March let me let me get and so
literally I I was I was in I was no
cheating you know at that very time you
know they they were very anti
administration of it I have this memory
of like you know shouting crazily being
nineteen years old of the march through
the streets of Calvin Hill in Seattle
just screaming [ __ ] power yes Bush
power knows that compliance things still
kicking in but a little bit at least you
were you were out in the open I was out
in the open I I think I kind of started
to feel a little bit more free or at
least not constantly monitored for the
first time and what's weird and we'll
get to this later is how Tay Zonday
blowing up and coming into you know I
mean I hate to say but it is kind of
worldwide fame I walk down the street in
London and people will be like that guy
right I can't escape it kind of brought
that panopticon's back oh wow that yep I
had grown up with and all of the
psychology and all of the reluctance and
all of the issues that are kind of
involved in that sense of always being
monitored it's it's back again and
really we can talk about next the dots
of how we got there and then we'll
explore that
so you're marching in the Dyke March
that's their name not ours and then you
go home and you write Chocolate Rain
about that experience there's an 8 year
gap here ok right we actually need to
discover I do it well I kind of already
covered it like I was in SIA
Capitol Hill in Seattle for a year and a
half moved down to finish my undergrad
to Olympia Washington Capitol City
Washington beautiful Evergreen State
College very evergreen if you ever go
there
one of the most beautiful landscapes
anywhere especially when it's sunny it's
it is sometimes overcast there but a
beautiful place on the Pacific Northwest
and while I was there at Evergreen I had
an advisor who said that he had gotten
his PhD in American Studies at Bowling
Green's and he suggested that I apply to
American Studies programs because I I
just kind of had this assumption when I
finished my undergrad that hey I've been
in school 16 years why don't I stay in
school another 7 and get a PhD I think
it was kind of that part of the the boy
in me who was like lieutenant commander
data who who just wanted to be smarter
to be smarter and so basically I pursued
a PhD for all of the wrong reasons not
because I was super super passionate
about a project that needed the solution
of being research but because I just
wanted a gosh-darn PhD so you got a
Bowling Green no I did listen to the
adviser who went who got his PhD in
American Studies at Bowling Green
however and I applied to American
Studies programs because they allow you
to in some cases to be more
self-directed they kind of II study
history but also mix in humanities and
put other people on your committee who
kind of tailor your research interest to
you and the way he described it to me
it's like you know you know Adam you
know I I want to my my American Studies
PhD I don't even know what I wanted to
do till the second or thirty I'm like oh
that's great I have no idea what I want
to do this when I get a PhD
why don't I apply for that and so I
applied like six seven places Emory
communications University of Washington
etcetera University of Minnesota
accepted me with aid for 44 years of
funding and I got a fellowship the first
year which meant I didn't have to be a
teaching assistant which was cool so I
moved to Minneapolis and to be honest I
thought that in that period of life I
would still be passionate about social
movements and social change but I kind
of found it when I moved away from
Capitol Hill in Seattle and also you
know this is 2004 now so we're kind of
moving away from that historical moment
of post 9/11
- you know everything that followed I
never really found my footing in any
similar type of community like that in
Minneapolis and so I didn't really have
a research interest so to speak I you
know pursuing the PhD I would take the
coursework learn how to do ethnographic
you know anthropological research learn
how to do historical research but I was
surrounded by people who had passionate
life projects that that they were you
know say you know they they'd grown up
American Indian and they were just
researching American Indian land rights
or it was part of or you know they grew
up identifying it's queer and you know
they're studying you know sexuality and
and and feminism and all sorts things
and you didn't have something I didn't
have anything like that and so so did
you feel it seems like what you're
saying is that you felt different I
absolutely felt different and you know
one of the ways I responded to that
difference is I continued my lifelong
music hobby I've never been a serious
musician but I've always been a hobbyist
musician kind of doing it for fun and I
would start going to open mics in
Minneapolis around 2006 dragging
sometimes my in a 40-pound stage piano
with a 30 pound amp
I remember one cafe I went to which is
in a different part of the city it was
the middle of winter in Minneapolis I
literally had alligator cables tying a
30-pound amp to a 40-pound stage piano
I'm one of those little Airport
you know handcarts things yeah and I was
dragging it through the snow I on the
sidewalk on the sidewalk drug it in
through the snow left this little lake
of water in this cafe that had maybe ten
people in it and so it takes me ten
minutes to set up why don't you just get
a keyboard I know I had a keyboard I'm
dragging the stage piano and a stage
piano there's a keyboard yes it's big
it's still big but I basically remember
I'm play I'm taking forever to set up
I'm playing two songs they're singing
for ten people five of whom are not
paying attention the other five of whom
really don't care and then you know
putting it back together and going
you know into the shame of my car at
home and then YouTube comes along at
this point before YouTube the people who
knew you your friends did they what was
their interaction with you what was
their assessment of you did they
consider you different or you know Adams
you know he's weird guy I love him for
it was it that kind of thing
I imagine that people have found me to
be unique my entire life but you never I
have never felt like I could have just
that every day blending in and I think
that's one reason I was drew as a kid
because I wanted that so so badly
especially as an isolated teen and
perhaps even growing up into college I
think as a teen Ian I mean gosh I so
wanted to be just you know I seen kid
who was you know like listening to
unicorn and and and no fear and all the
band's there and and you know just kind
of like hanging out and having my posse
having my on the inside on the inside
this is who I just wanted to blend and I
so badly wanted to blend in and you know
it just never was it it wasn't in the
cards you know was it you know partly
freezing my parents partly reason who I
was I've just always stuck out but
you're I mean if you're saying if we
were to travel back in time and meet you
on the street and ask you what is your
life goal you would have said blend in
yet you're dragging a huge keyboard down
the snow and so almost in spite like
going on instinct this is these corner
inflicted my existence you are you are
highlighting the core in our conflict of
days on day the double identity that has
never resolved itself so YouTube comes
along so YouTube comes along I get sick
of dragging my keyboard or just playing
it open mics where nobody's listening
I'm like okay wait YouTube is there I
could just make videos in my living room
and maybe reach a larger audience than
me five or 10 people listening to me at
open mics so is the first video on
your channel now the first one you up no
no no no okay
the the videos on my channel I've been
very mercilessly pruned because Canon
and Zee original classical arrangement
yeah eight years ago is is and then you
have love an original song by kou be
featuring Tay Zonday and then the third
one that's still public is Chocolate
Rain yes
101 first of all the way I started on
YouTube January 2007 uh because you know
I was still known as Adam Bonner at this
point and I said I need to come up with
an alter-ego I want it to be something
that's not in use by anybody else and so
I kind of Google different very why why
need an alter-ego because I mean you had
a rapper know at that point I believed
my career would be to be a university
professor where I would be publishing
papers and I wanted that too habits on
Google life I wanted my career as an
academic as a researcher to have its own
life separate from my music career and
so I so a few people calculate the
beginning of a youtube channel
especially in 2007 that degree oh and
and even more so I wanted a name that if
people heard it they would know how it
was spelled if it was said in
conversation so that if they heard Tay
Zonday they would know Oh Tay Zonday
calm that I didn't want it to have an
ambiguous spelling and so I think I was
just entering different options on
Google like a gray Monday data and I
entered tayzonday in quotes on Google
and it got zero results really I'm I'm
gonna take YouTube calm down it's not
the top of your heads on day and say
don't mean anything in another language
or know that no they were there was an
inspired by something or it was created
as an alter-ego like just the words were
just like top of my life I'm just saying
Tay Zonday flake run I like the way it's
long bay I liked the way it rolled up
over the time the funny thing is is you
just said you wanted it to be something
that when people heard it in the
conversation they would know how to look
but the first time I heard it you
thought it was tazed on it thought was
tazed on day yeah that's the that's the
thing I wasn't thinking of like but you
knew how to spell it and if it was tazed
I probably would have been the same
feeling right there are no spaces still
would have gotten there but yes some
people come Ajay's on I'm like okay
whatever and that's almost kind of
something I because you know I blew up
so fast
so quickly that it kind of didn't make a
difference right yeah they did Matty's
on day she brings up Adam Bonner adam
Bonner brings up Tay Zonday now uh but
so you created a channel and then what
the first video I uploaded on YouTube
was my singing swing low Sweet Chariot
okay in the range of Paul Robeson and so
it was down like swing low Sweet Chariot
coming for to carry me home on the
keyboard and I loved that the feedback I
got on YouTube was characteristically
very honest they're kind of like my ears
are bleeding have you ever tried like
maybe you want to try Australian throat
singing you sound like a frog Tay this
is weird and maybe sometimes and these
are Fred's because when you start
YouTube whose watch well no I mean yeah
I mean I do but there was some organic
reach okay okay you what you could do is
you can add people as friends and then
after you added them as friend you could
invite them to subscribe or just synonym
it's just math in the video out audio
sorry early 2007 guess who was in my
first 15 YouTube friends that I added
let me let me guess yes
well now that you're looking at me I'm
thinking I'd be reading link please be
us no kid role Justin Bieber oh no it
was Justin Bieber
yeah and he was just a youtube you know
thank you I didn't live even just before
Justin Bieber he was that YouTube
channel
his mom was like hey you know my kid is
really great in my 12 yo was really
great at singing Michael Jackson and
playing drums yeah and which he was a
great singer but is this kind of a funny
tuba to YouTube history do you think he
saw swing low back then like you were
seeing them and he was seeing you I
liked it I'd like to think so I'd have
to ask him but I probably didn't invite
him to subscribe but in any case that's
kind of when I realized that that and a
couple other experiments that the super
low bass range probably was not going to
be Mike ticket to popularity on YouTube
and I actually started singing things an
octave higher in the baritone range
which is where Chocolate Rain and some
of the other songs that eventually reach
popularity wish to give yet I mean
you've already demonstrated it but you
know people already kind of I think the
layman already thinks of Chocolate Rain
and the rest of your music as being very
base E is how they would describe it to
begin with even though it's technically
a baritone yeah you know you approached
YouTube with such a confidence of
success in such a level of calculation I
would say you know when you say well
I've got to have an alter ego because
I'm gonna be a successful write a PhD
and then I'm gonna be successful on
YouTube under a name that you need to be
able to google and find because that's
part of the success and I'm even gonna
write an explanation for the actions
assuming people will be speculating
about it yet the calculation didn't
extend to the things that actually made
it such a such an explosion wouldn't you
agree I agree with that assessment so it
was it wasn't like nothing was
calculated and it was calculated and
that's the first that's one of the many
things I'm finding fascinating here was
the level of calculation that then set
up everything that you could never have
planned yeah brilliant absolutely there
was a tremendous amount of calculation
involved in laying the ground for what
then happened spontaneously and so tell
us how it happened I mean the eruption
what was the experience
it's for you like how did you even know
it was happening cuz it was delayed the
video was out there for a while you were
getting feedback people were probably
saying the same thing about Chocolate
Rain they said about love and the other
videos right and like I shouted earlier
um I don't think we edit it out haha
but Chocolate Rain was uploaded in April
of 2007 it got a little bit of traction
you know maybe twelve thousand views
from you know the front page feature the
other video but it largely set around it
was maybe at 30,000 views by June of
2007 and I think in early July someone
posted it on digg.com the social
bookmarking so basically read it but
back then and it was in the top of
digg.com
for maybe a week and the views doubled
to about 60,000 in that time someone saw
it on Digg calm posted it on 4chan and
then they just thought it was hilarious
and it kind of became a frank a a meme
there so to speak at this time what were
you doing yeah I did you were you were
following this I'm assuming you saw the
views going up I knew what was being
posted I didn't know any of this until
you know afterwards I was basically well
what was I doing that summer was I a
teaching assistant over this summer I'm
trying to remember summer of 2007 I
think I may have been off that summer I
can't I can't exactly remember but I
know I was the basically living the life
of a PhD student and a nerd in my living
room who just did music as a hobby so
when so in it so when it happened like
even the step one which is you know dig
going from 30 to 60 thousand views you
knew this was happening you can see
people's comments what's going through
your mind at that time is it
people are kid people people get this
people who like my music or is it these
operations hit me that something was
happening was wins
there was a 4chan thread where they
tried to prank call Tom Green and
successfully prank called Tom Green in
his web show that he did from his living
over the time and then the caller just
breaks out see
Chocolate Rain mm-hm and then I see Tom
Green County reacting Dada and the very
next day it's featured on Carson Daly
his late night show and then it just
becomes a national news story and
perhaps you know every way there is to
message me on youtube I have a contact
form on my website people were trying to
contact me to get in on this news story
of this video that is going viral and I
remember the first two weeks I did
perhaps 30 radio interviews all of them
terrible because I just had no sense of
being a public figure on that level why
what I mean just in the privacy of your
own mind what was your explanation this
is what it's like to have 15 minutes of
fame this is what it's like to be a
national news story but specifically
because now you've already articulated
this you you understand exactly why it
blew up but at the time as it was
blowing up how did that realization come
about and what were you thinking in that
first interview when somebody talked to
you um unfortunately this is still on
YouTube might take somewhere well no
what was my first interview it was with
of all people Opie and Anthony in New
York press the first radio interview I
ever did and I followed a conversation
about what percentage of the ocean is
composed of whale semen and you know
when you're doing the phone interview
they have like with a segment that you
can pour it right here what's going and
it's like well you know like up to 20
percent of the ocean might be composed
of well junk oh and here's the guy next
you're not gonna believe it but he's
blowing up on this YouTube thing we've
got the guy it stays hot there the
chocolate or whatever and I remember I
was very self-deprecating in the first
interviews what it really what really
stands out about most of the interviews
I've done about Chocolate Rain is people
try to peg me into turning it into a
polemic interview they say well clearly
this is making a political statement a
and he's there a deeper meaning
they're a are you trying to say
something like that and I have always
shied away from being that so it so
called you know Malcolm X figure or
polemic political figure with Chocolate
Rain is the basis only because while
obviously there is a political message
or there is a social justice message to
it people who experience it they come
from all sorts of different experiences
someone will say hey my two-year-old
can't stop saying this at bedtime
hey you know I I love the way you move
away from the bike to breathe in or this
is just this was so funny we just passed
this around the office at work and yeah
I I would have validate those
experiences and then maybe 10 20 % of
people or actually listening to the
lyrics and say okay you know there's a
deeper critique there's a groupers a
deeper social message here Kanye was
very nice I think he's jotted without in
this song saying that I tayzonday was
deep and and is that was that your
intention in the lyrics did you want to
talk about that I absolutely did and I
think especially when it comes to social
justice people are turned off by
polemics people don't want to be
preached to and so I sing about what I
can't say about but summarize it for us
well I think I just did I always say the
question is more important than the
answer in terms of if Chocolate Rain can
get people asking the question hey what
does Chocolate Rain mean then we are in
an interrogative space but we have moved
from having no conversation to at least
they're being a question but I mean I
understand that you know rock jock radio
DJs are gonna ask that question because
they want to know what the hell it means
so to speak but what didn't they really
just want you to be weird so they could
laugh at you I mean oh absolutely and I
mean that was a really it was a hard
aspect of the way in which I blew up
because let's be honest I blew up for
the incidental comedy in some regards of
chocolate rain for the unintended comedy
and there would be
asking in the comments can I laugh at
this beacon not knowing whether or not I
intended it seriously and I mean my
response to that has always been hey if
I do something and you want to laugh at
it and it makes your day a little bit
brighter makes your life a little bit
brighter go ahead that's fine but I
think the problem what I did interviews
in appearances and sometimes in that
period of my life is that people would
expect me to show up and do that
deliberately
and as we've already covered I get into
trouble when I try to be funny doing you
weren't Trump but I try to do deliver a
comedy it doesn't work they just have to
be me but I'm really interested in the
realization you know there's a more
stark example of this there's a guy
there's a few documentaries about Kyle
just go white I don't have you ever
heard of this this is this guy it's
called just go white the mountain dancer
a guy in West Virginia who kind of rose
to fame and then in the 80s or the 90s
it's just he was a very very interesting
personality and had like this alter ego
that was Elvis Presley and stuff and he
became he kind of rose to national fame
it was on Oprah and it was in that
moment of him taking that first trip so
to speak to Hollywood where he started
realizing that people were laughing at
him and he and he basically just had an
implosion it sounds like he was very
sincere in his mountain dancing yeah it
sounds it because you came up a
different way through the internet uses
that you got to see people's
interpretation of your work from the
very beginning so it wasn't a surprise
that people found it funny no you know
what was funny is I actually found the
hate on the Internet refreshing at first
and I say this because when you sing it
open mics in Minneapolis I love
Minnesota I love Minnesotans they're not
really that confrontational like you
perform in New York New Yorkers will
tell you exactly what they think about
you like you say how did I do
okay maybe not my thing whatever you
know whatever in in Minnesota you never
get that type of feedback performing
live they're always kind of like so I
came to YouTube like starving for honest
feedback about who I did what I was and
so uh I certainly got it
I certainly you know that people are
unrestrained on the
I would say that post chuckling because
that's really the question that it's
segues into is what happened after
Chocolate Rain blew up and who did I
want to be is that right did I I've
always had this struggle of okay
there's part of me who wants to be quote
unquote
a serious actor series entertainer
seriously I love dramatic acting I love
being on sets I love you know playing
the more naturally I would actually play
them the role of authority you know the
governor the senator the Chief of Police
etcetera the things working against that
are AI look way too young
no one would ever cast me for that right
now and be you know it I think there's
also kind of like that there's that
historical aspect where it's like you
know Chocolate Rain blew up because
people were just entertained by it and
it's not a type of entertainment that I
was able to reproduce Calculon liberally
to calculate and I think you mean you
started earlier the conversation talking
about well the dearth of what where my
videos on each of who I haven't been
uploading on YouTube I have by the way
been on twitch a lot I'm like I'm given
yet five six hours a night at twitch.tv
slash Tay Zonday games tears other games
but I think one of the struggles that I
had with YouTube over the past seven
years is I could not reproduce the
entertainment value of Chocolate Rain as
deliberate comedy it was incidental it
was just me being me and honestly being
me as nobody in the sense of being
nobody it just screwing around saying
hey I'll put this up and whatever
happens will happen and it's almost kind
of like that classic got in Avedon story
where it's like before Eve at the Apple
she did not know she was naked and
suddenly uh you know I blow up with
Chocolate Rain and I'm not Jimmy Kimmel
and I do the dr. pepper video and it's
just this energizer bunny that keeps
going and going and going I'm parodied
on South Park in 2008 the next year I
want a YouTube award when a webby award
do stuff with several attacks and kind
of incidentally become this odd icon who
is tied to the internet because even
today people who don't remember
Chocolate Rain and don't remember the
name Tay Zonday they'll stare at me from
across say the DMV and say sure that guy
from the internet you did that video
from the internet yeah from the internet
you you are the Internet
oh yeah I somehow kind of became in
people's minds in iconography of the
internet and Internet success and and
blowing up on the internet and and
what-have-you but and I have to go back
a little bit before we keep moving
forward and how do you build on or move
forward from chocolate rain is just you
talk about the moment of realization
when Eve eats the Apple absolutely but
for you is that what is the realization
is it you seem to say it was what I did
that made me so successful I didn't do
intentionally but I want to ask was
there also a realization that you bite
the Apple and then it's oh no people are
laughing at me not with me because I
wasn't intending to be funny so here I
am on Kimmel who am just so you can
laugh at me some more
I mean was there a struggle there how do
you play that that's the funny you play
that and what's that what's the what's
the end what's the conclusion
Oh know yourself this is the ongoing
struggle of my career because you have
entertainers who build successful
careers being laughed at carrot top you
know but he's a comedian he's cracking
just my point is like that like what is
that is a distinct career path and like
I think that has always kind of been the
crossroads in my career even when
Chocolate Rain was blowing up it's like
I have nothing against hypothetically
the career path or people who take the
career path of being left Act and but
when it's you there's a moment where you
might be hurt by that or you can either
harness it be hurt by it or I would
assume both I
think there was some of both I think
here's what I you know hindsight is
always 20/20 and I'm not gonna say that
I have regrets but I will say that you
know you look at what what Miranda sings
has done it's very successful she's kind
of taken and and you know that's not a
real name but she created the Miranda
sings character as this over-the-top
character to be laughed at and she's
actually extremely extremely talented
singer but Miranda sings is the
obnoxious you know put lipstick on to do
it and and do the whole you know you get
internet views show two brilliant
brilliant businessman in retrospect be
because I had this inner conflict that
you're describing I didn't embrace Tay
Zonday like say a Miranda sings and just
take it and run with it and say hey yeah
you know I'm the guy who moves very for
Mike to breathe that and do this and
this you know and I think it would have
been a more successful business that
blew up more if I had kind of been
willing to stomach the reality that the
way to grow it in that moment was to
just accept being laughed at and create
Tay Zonday is this alter ego of being
laughed at and but even ones are the
life thing I think what happened instead
is that it kind of became this odd thing
that I I I wanted to personally identify
my of course it did because it the
difference between you and Miranda is
that Miranda was created about Colleen I
mean we talked to her on the show but it
was you expressing yourself and then you
find that people reacting in this way
and of course it was a it's a lot more
complicated for you in that moment in
that volcanic explosion of viral video
to figure out people are interpreting me
yeah it's a moniker you made up a name
but you were just it was you
absolutely it was not a deliberate
character so it was but what so was
there a moment of biting the Apple oh my
gosh they're laughing at me or I don't
know if it was a moment of I don't know
if I can take it on a particular moment
I would
say what I knew from the experiences
that I had in the summer 2007 and the
fall thereafter I had a lot of either
pretty intense experiences I mean I was
opening for Girl Talk at First Avenue
you know the most name is called
Minneapolis you know dr. pepper video
that got huge it was of course you know
of kind of a very different portrayal of
me and in an exaggerated way and on
Kimmel I mean that it's amazing and the
front page of Sunday's another da it you
know it's I knew that I needed a lot
more time to figure out who I was then
the moment of being hot would allow
because everyone was telling me when I
was that in that moment and I think even
for a week or two correct me if I'm
Robert I think if you look at the
history of Google trending topics
Chocolate Rain Tay Zonday is like number
one number two for like a week or two in
July of 2007 everyone was telling me in
that moment it's like okay you're hot
now whatever you're doing now this
moment may never come again in your life
so there is a tremendous pressure on me
just to go from being a nerd in my
living room to suddenly and by the way
we're still in graduate school it's cool
this point I decided not to drop out I
still thought I'd be finishing the PhD
so I tried to mix them both you know
there was a tremendous pressure to try
and make the most of this moment and I
think my response in that aha moment was
just to realize hey I'm not going to be
able to be the person I need to be to
take the best advantage of this moment
of being hot I'm just not going to be
there and that's okay I'm just going to
keep trying to be me and explore being
me and I probably have many more years
of doing that to figure out who I am and
who I want to become and that's exactly
what I did I stayed in grad school I
continued uploading YouTube occasionally
and kind of did the same thing uh and
and that to some extent that's why I
came to youtube I came to it as an
experiment to get feedback and who I was
and learned to be who I was but well
it's um
like you found yourself in a place where
it an Impala would call this an
impossible position to try to calculate
a miscalculation to become I love that
to become intentional about something
that was unintentional now the the
fascinating thing is that you have you
have made a career that was based upon
that you know the biting the the but not
the biting the Apple but the the raining
of the chocolate and then the the
eventually kind of realizing what that
was that was happening and how has that
unfolded and what does it mean for you
as a as an entertainer now well here's
the silver lining of having a lot of
people laugh at you uh and and what I
kind of realized and this is maybe how I
made peace with it okay is that it you
know if you have if if you just have
exposure of any type whatever type of
exposure that is assuming it's not
negative exposure you know people
laughing it is not necessarily negative
exposure some people will look at that
and they'll take it seriously and
they'll try to just because you got in
front of their eyeballs you will have an
opportunity to develop a more serious
relationship with them and you will have
an opportunity to then kind of get to be
a wait okay yeah I realize you laugh at
that okay that was funny that but when
you get to know me I'd say that knowing
me in person is a pretty different
experience than just you know watching
Chocolate Rain and laughing at it and
that's kind of been what what drove my
career is you know I would post content
on YouTube there is always that YouTube
audience it saw it for whatever reason
I've tried posting more serious things
on YouTube there is a smaller audience
for that there's a smaller audience for
example for my singing somewhere over
the rainbow from Wizard of Oz I think I
did a decent job of that you know bring
him home from lame is I've done more
serious stuff on my youtube channel and
I think I've you know done some semi
competently but it is true the audience
for that has
never been as large yes it is a
different card for a different thing for
my you know like singing call me maybe
an add a point based voice in turn being
entertaining in that way I mean yeah I
mean certainly I've questioned with just
conversations with you over the years
when you'd like brush shoulders at an
event or something but that well is it
it but is he affecting his voice and
when he goes home and he's like just
hanging out or like going through a
drive-thru that it's like okay he's it
goes up another octave
I mean he's you know there is a question
but but I mean I took your explanation
of being that kid who wanted to be older
to be in that old soul that it might
have been that your voice was something
that maybe use you've settled into
something that was an affectation of
wanting to be older at a younger age did
you talk like this before YouTube it's
funny what do you say talk like this
because what I wake I'm when I'm going
on I think of me as like someone who
talks like this like that like what this
is what what is this and that that's the
question what is the this of Tay Zonday
talking like this um did I talk about
this before my voice was deep probably I
mean I I would assume I was always
cerebral intellectual reflective uh
aloof to some extent well III don't mean
to go back to the shallow end of the
pool here I'm not trying to to do that
by going back to the voice I was just
acknowledging that I think people just
you know they want to be fascinated to a
certain degree and then they just want
to believe that I'll you affect his
voice or that's the simplest solution
that's the more entertaining solution
explanation so your knowing you the
messages this is me guys
I am a person and I like to say things
and have thoughts and have conversations
and I am actually and I'm not interested
in that I'm not a cartoon not a cartoon
and I think you're right there's there
is that is kind of the struggle that
I've always had on YouTube it's not just
a story
being taken seriously but it kind of is
for whatever reason me and my natural
state uh on cameras I present myself on
YouTube people don't know whether to
believe that is real they don't know
whether to believe that's a real person
whom they can have a relationship with
they they can't imagine when they watch
Chocolate Rain sitting next to me on the
bus how does that make you feel about
opportunities that are gonna continue to
come for the rest of your life for you
to be that guy that people laugh on the
internet you know I just like to say
that I am passionate about working
I don't really complain about the
context because I'm old enough and wise
enough to know that any type of exposure
including good-natured humor is exposure
that you know if ten thousand people
watch it maybe two people will be
watching that who then initiate a
serious relationship where they get to
know me and maybe that's a work
relationship maybe that's something
that's very serendipitous
and so exposure is ultimately king and
then the money's still green right I
mean I guess I mean I'm guest starring
in a couple episodes of what is it on
Adult Swim now they jack and triumph
show which is very fun very fun to be on
set I love acting like if I had a choice
watch it with my career I love being on
sets I love the lights the camera having
a crew yeah in my face I love being cast
and and and and embodying a role I just
I love it to tears and one reason I
think I love it is because I'm I'm I can
let go in a fictional space in a way
that I cannot let go in real life and I
feel more real acting in a fictional
context then I actually do with real
people in real life and that harkens
back to the car tuna fication of Tay
Zonday to this sense that when I am
actually real in real life and it's not
an acting set somehow I'm taken as this
cartoon somehow I'm taken as something
that is fantasy and not reality and
it's almost like when I'm in fantasy
when I am on set when I am acting when I
am able to actually be a character I
feel more real and more incisive and
more on top of my game as a human being
than I do anywhere else including in
real life well that's interesting and
you know we wish you the best and acting
and everything else that you do but we
appreciate you being real here I think
you certainly have been real here so
thanks for creating this here biscuit
I think thanks for that thank you so
much for having me and there you have it
our chocolate biscuit with chocolate
covered with a zine dipped and covered
and smothered in chocolate rain let teh
know that you appreciated his ear
biscuit with us you can do that using
hashtag ear biscuits at his Twitter Tay
Zonday ta y z o nday I really appreciate
it I mean this is what I'm gonna tweet
okay hey man thanks for for being so
open and so introspective you know I'm
I'm glad that he was willing to go there
and you know I mean he's I think it was
clear that he had thought about his
experience but I do feel like maybe we
brought him back to it and helped him
process it in one place I like to feel
like we've done that at least even even
if no one's listening like you are
listening and I'm glad you're listening
but and I'm not saying it's therapy and
I'm not saying that they needs therapy
because that that would be the wrong
thing to say I'm really digging a hole
for my sky no I'm just gonna see how you
swim out of this bucket of chocolate
right wait a second I just enjoy having
conversation with people to get them to
process their experience in one sitting
especially when there's kind of lights
going off and we're reaching conclusions
that maybe they hadn't thought about but
it's not therapy yeah you know I'm
saying that Tay it's well I think the
thing that we've talked to people who
are known for something
and then I mean ultimately every
youtuber every entertainer ultimately
has that thing that most people
recognize them for right I mean there's
very few people that have this this
really even-handed body of work this
everybody has the thing that they broke
out with he happens to be he is such a
right place right time 2007
unintentional so big like although you
don't think that if if he if Chocolate
Rain hadn't existed until tomorrow in it
the internet no it wouldn't work no I
know it would work but it wouldn't be it
would not be the sensation that it was
it I believe that it had to do with the
time in which people were thirsty for
chocolate rain and things like that
IIIi people are still as thirsty today I
think that I'm trying to think of the
other people that we've talked to who
had started with some unintentional
success I think there were a number of
ear biscuits I the only one that's
coming to mind is glozell though I'm
interested to go back and listen to that
one yeah because you know she kind she
was she was doing a character but then
it was so there was some intentionality
to it just like there was what they was
doing but it but it blew up in a way
that she didn't anticipate yeah we had
to react in that and that's the
interesting thing because we're not
talking unintentional in the way like
okay you were filmed falling into a
fountain right and you became super
famous for it no no he created a piece
of art he created something that people
authentically like for all because of
all the the intentional decisions he
made that's the wonderful unintentional
consequences of intentional decision
when you describe the elements of
chocolate rain to make chocolate rain
great
that's all intentional but like he made
the decision to move away from the mic
to breathe he made the decision to put
text on the screen but he didn't
necessarily know that that would be that
one of the things that made it
entertaining for people so and now that
I love that dynamic I love the fact that
he understands that that was the
mechanism that created it
he still can't calculate it he can only
channel it like I think that was you
know when he talked about a sense of
humor in the tweets like well when I try
to be funny
it might come across as creepy but when
I'm just putting something out there
people are going to respond to I kind of
have to trust that it I'm gonna unto
unintentionally create something through
intentionally trying to do something
else I'm gonna intentionally do
something unintentional right well I
think what you're saying like is that
you can't make it Chocolate Rain but
when it does Chocolate Rain it's gonna
take it and use it to your advantage
I mean even in the song biscuit we we
did I mean you were reviewing the edit
and describing to me that the phenomenon
have kind of letting him loose at the
end of the song there I believe that it
was for me personally the most
entertaining song biscuit to date and
the most entertaining part for me was at
the end where Tay takes the lead and we
kind of move into the background and
just repeat a line over and over again
and he just kind of goes to a Tay Zonday
place signature holding up of both hands
at the same time the facial expression
at a tone it was a privilege to be there
melody choice of that yes it was great
it was you know I hope you'll enjoy that
you know you can put a song biscuit on
top of your ear biscuit and make a
biscuit sandwich you know we could we
could analyze our experience forever
we're gonna keep doing that but you are
free to move along with the rest of your
life or to the near next ear biscuit and
just keep listening maybe you're on a
road trip we'll see if we see those
tweets I'm I'm getting on a plane I'm
downloaded a whole bunch of your
biscuits whatever you do you can count
on us to keep baking the biscuits Lauria
sheet by sheet on a weekly basis like
chocolate right
[Music]
[Music]